da bin ich relativ spontan ich habe ein bisschen zeug aus ich habe meine steam
library durchgeguckt bisschen zeug aus dem angeguckt nämlich festgestellt ich
habe bock auf nix deswegen habe ich einfach mal den stream angemacht
ja ja ja ja ja cringe kein kein stream heute ich habe auch nix geplant betke
betke ist in betke ist in 145 betke auf origin ja auf origin was macht
eigentlich wenn es gerade das mal kurz checken das war kurz mal eine gucken was
meint ihr was ist der was ist der meistbesuchte wenn es so aber ich tippe
auf fünf leute kurz checken kurz checken
acht klar dass da nix los ist
wahrscheinlich ist auch noch ein server mit bots drauf so ja keine ahnung der
server namen habe ich gar nicht gelesen habe ich jetzt gar nicht anguckt was
ist das aber was war das war das top mal das monka tostserver namen
most played vr server ja gut mit zehn slots
sind wir jetzt eigentlich nicht na ja ich finde das also generell ist und also
ist sinnlos gehyped zu sein eigentlich in der regel immer nicht gut also ich
tippe ja drauf dass es schon ein geiles battlefield wird aber das garantiert
wieder zwei drei sachen drin sind die richtig abfacken
ich meine wir wissen nicht wie sich der kram spielt es gibt ja gibt ja bald eine
beta oder warte mal wann war die ich habe schon siebte achte ne
wann war mal mal neu war wa du failed bitte an warten das noch mal
grey
zu battlefield 20 2 42 alles klar
Wo steht denn der Termin jetzt? September, also irgendwie siebter, siebter neunter oder
irgendwie sowas war das, war das glaube ich geleakt mal, naja also spätestens dann wissen
wir ob das Game was taucht, das ist so ein bisschen wie, das wird so ein bisschen wie
die Beta von New World jetzt, New World, New Worlds, New World heißt es genau, also alles
was dann kacke sein wird an dem Game, wird bei Release auch noch kacke sein, hör von
ausgehen, fand es ja wieder lustig, in meinem Video konnten sich die Leute ja wieder nicht
einigen, ob ich das Spiel jetzt zu sehr lobe oder zu schlecht mache, New Worlds, ich muss
sagen ich hab jetzt gar nicht mehr so großartig gespielt, bei mir war nach Level, keine Ahnung
18 oder so, war knapp, war die Luft raus, das Problem ist ich wollte eigentlich spielen
bis zuerst, bis zum ersten PvM Raid, hab ich aber nicht gemacht, weil das, also es ist
ja normal, ich hab ja nichts dagegen wenn MMOs Kreiselcrimes sind und ich hab ja auch
nichts dagegen wenn MMOs sich irgendwie wiederholen, aber New World war ja im Endeffekt statt
Quest Board, klick klick klick, einmal im Kreis laufen, statt Quest Board, klick klick
klick, einmal im Kreis laufen, also das war mir dann auch zu dumm, ansonsten hab ich nach
wie vor die Vermutung, dass viele Mechaniken in dem Spiel nicht genug Tiefgang bieten
auf Dauer, tja, aber mal gucken, es ist auf jeden Fall das einzige was Amazon noch irgendwie,
das einzige wie sagt man schon, das einzige Eisen was Amazon noch im Feuer hat, auch total
boomerspruch, nee das ist eigentlich noch im Mittelalterspruch eher, das einzige Eisen
was Amazon noch im Feuer hat, alles andere haben sie verkackt, Herr der Ringe MMO haben
sie eingestellt, Leute ich sag's euch, ich sag's euch, ich sag's euch wie es ist, Amazon
möchte ja eine Herr der Ringe Serie machen, ich sag euch die wird sacken, ich könnte,
ich mach ich nicht, aber ich könnte meinen Arsch drauf verwenden, dass die Serie sacken
wird, wann auch immer die rauskommen, man weiß es ja gar nicht, ich glaube wirklich
das Portal gar nicht so der Hammer wird für die meisten Leute, weil es ist halt kein Map
Editor, es ist ein Spielmodus Editor, ich weiß nicht ob das reicht wahnsinnig interessante
Dinge zu machen, in Overwatch ist das auch eher so ein Gimmick, dass es sowas gibt,
man kann natürlich in Portal deutlich mehr machen, als man es in Overwatch Custom Lobbys
machen kann, wie kann man Daten von einer Bluetooth Waage auslesen, du musst ja erstmal
das Protokoll raussuchen, also nicht Bluetooth sondern das Custom oder weiß ich auch was
Protokoll nennt, das Format in dem die Bluetooth Waage Sachen versendet, also wenn die Sachen
verschlüsselt sind und der Key nicht öffentlich ist, hast du eh wahrscheinlich gelitten,
aber bei den meisten halbwegs verbreiteten Sachen, haben das schon findige Leute aus
den Apps extrahiert, ich muss mich mal ordentlich hinsetzen, sonst pinche ich gleich ein, das
heißt du musst erstmal am besten nach dem Typ der Waage suchen, dann guckst du ob es
irgendjemand gibt, der schon das Protokoll bzw. das Format der Daten irgendwie rausbekommen
hat, wie das verschickt wird und dann nimmst du dir irgendeinen Controller und liest den
Kram aus, musst du selbst programmieren oder es gibt schon was fertiges, am einfachsten
ist natürlich mit der offiziellen App von der Waage, aber dann hast du auch die gleichen
Beschränkungen und im Zweifelsfall China Cloud, China-Chinesen Cloud am Start, macht
da eigentlich Aliexpress und sind da wieder die Versand, sind bei Aliexpress eigentlich
jetzt immer endlich die Versandkosten wieder normal, kurz checken, ja natürlich kauf mir
schnell ein Auto bei Aliexpress, auf gehts, bam, oh super, das haben, was zum geil soll
das sein, was ist das, eine Matratze für den Kofferraum, ok, China Zeug, wird das ein
Resident Sleeper oder Five Head Stream, weiß ich nicht, sind die Versandkosten wieder normal,
zeig her, Aliexpress, ich will das nicht kaufen, Chips from Frankreich, ok die Versandkosten,
wow, warum ist das auf einmal, Alter, äh, aner stellt es da nicht zurück, warum kann
ich nur einen bestellen über Safer Shipping, was ist das für Gebate, kostenloser Versand,
jawoll, die haben es auch auf einen beschränkt, also man kann echt bei den China-Chinesen
grad nicht bestellen, kannst du das Video zum ersten Ausbildungstag vor dem zweiten
und achten hochladen, ja ich hab mir überlegt ob ichs am Wochenende mach, also hier so irgendwann,
ich muss mal gucken, ich muss aber noch irgendwas anderes hochladen in der Zwischenzeit, das
sind ja Videos die jetzt nicht so viele Leute interessiert, das interessiert die Leute die
eine Ausbildung machen oder anfangen, aber insgesamt ist jetzt nicht so viel, einfach
5 mal bestellen, ja wenns kostenlos ist kann man das machen, aber die sind nicht doof,
die sind nicht doof, gibt es eigentlich, da hab ich lange nicht mehr drauf geguckt auf
den Channel, hat er eigentlich neue Battlefield 3 Top Plays, nö, gibt keine mehr, keiner
spielt bei Battlefield 3, oh, ich hab gehört, wir haben bei den Olympischen Spielen im Tresur-Reiten
wieder gewonnen, meine absolut Lieblingssportart, Tresur-Reiten, ganz ganz spannend, also es
gibt glaub ich kaum eine mehr Residenz-Sleeper-Sportart als Tresur-Reiten, nix gegen Tresur-Reiter,
weißte es einer von euch macht, aber ich bezweifle es, ja gut, in dem Fall, das stimmt, das stimmt,
keine Ahnung, ich hab das doch nicht geguckt, ich hab nur heute zufällig gelesen, dass wir
ne Medaille gewonnen haben, ist mir auch vollkommen egal, wenn ich ehrlich bin, also Tresur-Reiten
könnte mich kaum weniger interessieren, 20 Jahre Kubernetes-Erfahrung, ja, muss sein,
also unter 20 Jahre Kubernetes-Erfahrung würd ich dich auch nicht einstellen, ach, ich weiß
gar nicht, ich glaub so, ich glaub so, es ist auf jeden Fall anstrengender als vorm Rechner
sitzen. Competition, ich frag mich eh, wann es E-Sport gibt bei Olympia. Das Olympische
CS-Turnier, das wär doch mal was, oder? Langsam ist es echt mal an der Zeit, was da teilweise
für merkwürdige Sportarten am Start sind, von denen ich noch nie was gehört hab, und
ich sag euch, es würde definitiv Aufmerksamkeit bringen, dann habt ihr natürlich wieder die
Boomer-Leute, die sagen, was, das, das ist doch kein Sport, den Scheiß da, den will
ich mir nicht angucken, so, haste da wieder genug Leute, aber es würde auf jeden Fall
Aufmerksamkeit bringen, also ich würd mir lieber das Olympische CS-Turnier angucken,
als Tresur reiten. Gibt's schon relativ lange. Haben wir doch letztens erst gemacht. Die
Chinesen haben ein Zollproblem, na, eigentlich haben die sich ja da ganz gut drauf vorbereitet
mit Warenlager in der EU, oder eben nach Niederlande oder Spanien schicken. Die chinesischen,
China-Chinesen, ja. Was hat hier jemand? Ein Link, damit man Azure-Test-Coins bekommt.
Ne, ich weiß gar nicht, was Azure-Test-Coins sind. Aber jetzt ein Partnerprogramm, wo man
Leute werben kann. Ach, haben wir uns eigentlich schon das, ja, das haben wir uns angeguckt,
JetBrains. Das wollte ich mir mit euch aber noch ein bisschen näher angucken, genau, die
Abstimmung von JetBrains zu Programmiersprachen und Verwendung von Betriebssystemen und sowas,
das fand ich eigentlich ganz spannend. Die Seite ist irgendwie ein bisschen zu rechtsbündig,
oder? Die sollte eigentlich, ich hab den Eindruck, die Seite sollte eigentlich eher ein bisschen
mehr zentriert sein. Ach so, gratis testen kannst du bei Azure, na gut, da brauchst du
eine neue Handy-Nummer, ja. Mit der neuen Handy-Nummer kannst du deinen Probo-Account machen. Brauchst
neuen Accounten und eine Handy-Nummer. Dann kannst du, fragt mich nicht, was da, Basic,
100 Euro, Dollar, keine Ahnung. Wollen sie das? Hab ich noch nix von gehört. Die sollen
wir alle mal machen. Joa. Habt ihr das eigentlich mitbekommen, dass die Apotheken, ich weiß,
das ist jetzt auch schon ein paar Tage halt, wahrscheinlich ist es schon wieder News von
gestern, ja, aber habt ihr das mitbekommen mit den Apotheken und dem Corona-Zertifikat,
dass alle Apotheken wohl den gleichen Private Key benutzen, um die Zertifikate auszustellen?
Und dass es dementsprechend keinen Weg gibt, quasi gefakte Corona-Zertifikate zurückzurufen,
das ist, das ist echt typisch Big-Brain-Technik wieder, gut. Was macht eigentlich so der europäische
Impfpass? Gibt's den jetzt und kann man den benutzen? Ist, es ist so ein Geficke. Gatschi-Buzz,
also ich hab, ich hab ja erst eine Impfung, aber ich hatte irgendwelche QR-Codes zum
Scannen. Ach, keine Ahnung. Zweifelsfall nehme ich irgendein Zettel mit. Ja, aber, aber das
benutzt wahrscheinlich kaum einer oder es gibt irgendwelche Probleme. Hey, wenn der
Private Key geleakt sein sollte, könnte ich mir einfach selbst das ausstellen. Echt, was
ist? Ich habe auf Twitter gelesen von einem, der mit Herzmuskelentzündung ins Krankenhaus,
also einen, den ich kenne, mit Herzmuskelentzündung ins Krankenhaus gekommen ist nach der Impfung
mit BioNTech. Ja, ist trotzdem Fail. Also macht's ja nicht besser, nur weil's vor dem Launchklammer.
Ist halt für, naja, letztendlich, ich erwarte ja da auch schon gar nichts mehr. Ja gut, die
haben's eh verkackt. Also ich krieg meine zweite Impfung am, lass mal gucken, ich glaube,
am 23.08. krieg ich, oh Moment. Wie sind die eigentlich auf die dumme Idee gekommen, dass
der Pfeil nach oben in den Monat zurückgeht? Total hängen geblieben, Microsoft. Wahrscheinlich
am, ich glaube hier, ich glaube am 23.08. Also ich hatte nix, mir hat der Arm ein bisschen
wehgetan, also ich hatte gar nix davon. Also gut, es ist natürlich individuell, aber ich
kann schon von mir sagen, ich hatte gar nix. Ich hatte ein bisschen Kopfweh und ein bisschen,
dass mir der Arm wehgetan hat, wenn ich drauf gelegen hab zwei Tage, aber sonst, ich hatte
eigentlich nix. Haut erst bei der zweiten rein, MonkaS, der Chat macht mir aber Mut
drauf, aber eins sag ich euch, eins sag ich euch, ich hab ja den Terminshot, ich lass
mich auch impfen, ich find das auch ne wichtige Sache, dass man das macht, aber sollte irgendeiner
auf die Idee kommen, mich zwingen zu wollen, dann sag ich ab, das sag ich euch. Wenn irgendjemand
wirklich auf die Idee kommt und sich quasi über meinen Kopf hinweg entscheidet, was
ich zu tun hab oder zu lassen hab, dann sag ich das ab. Also ihr könnt euch sagen, so
viel ihr wollt, wenn irgendjemand sagt, es besteht Pflicht, dass ich das machen muss
unter Androhung von Strafe, dann mach ich das nicht. Das seh ich nicht ein. Auch wenn
ich's sinnvoll finde und mich auch freiwillig, ich lass mich freiwillig impfen, keine Probleme,
aber nicht unter Androhung von Strafe. Sollte irgendjemand auf die Idee kommen zu sagen,
das ist Pflicht, ansonsten musste ich keine Ahnung, Bußgeld bezahlen, dann könnt ihr
mich am Arsch lenken. Das seh ich nicht ein. Das ist, mein Körper, das ist meine komplett
freie Entscheidung, das soll's auch bleiben, ich mach's, weil ich's sinnvoll finde, aber
nicht, weil irgendjemand sagt, ich muss es machen. Ja, ähm, ist das echt so? Ich lass
mich, ich, ich, ich lass mir die trotzdem, bäm, 23. Hau, lass ich mir das Ding reinhauen,
gut ist. Vielleicht ist es auch 16, ich glaub, es ist, es ist ein Montag im August und, und
es ist ein zweistelliger Montag und es ist nicht der, ich glaub, es ist der 23. Ja, genau,
beim Armschmerzen hatte ich auch, das war's. Es wird ja sogar empfohlen, dass man die zweite
quasi mit was anderem macht. Spackhack, danke schon für 6 Monate, ich hoffe, ich hab kein
Zap übersehen. Nee, sieht nicht so aus. Wird da teilweise sogar empfohlen, dass man
eine andere als zweite Impfung nimmt. Ja, die chinesischen, China-Chinesen haben echt
kein Problem mit dem Versand, wie es aussieht. Ich seh schon, bei einigen ging es ab hier.
Wie gesagt, ich kenn einen auf Twitter, der musste ins Krankenhaus mit Herzmuskelentzündung
hat da geschrieben, das war auch richtig MonkaS. Stonks geht ab, Leute. Okay, also ich seh
schon mal, der meiste ist eigentlich kein Problem. Naja. Ich fand's so interessant
mit dem Zertifikat bei den Apotheken, so nach dem Motto, warum haben die ein Private Key
für alles? Keine Ahnung, wer sich das wieder ausgedacht hat. Und übrigens, wisst ihr was,
gestern wieder, nee, stimmt nicht. Ja, Mist, Leute, jebaited, das hab ich nicht gestern
gemacht. Letzte Woche schon. Was ich letzte Woche wieder verlängert hab, ich hab letzte
Woche wieder verlängert, YouTube Premium, aber, aber nicht einfach YouTube Premium,
sondern ich hab wieder über Indien bestellt. Guck mal, hier kostet es 12 Euro im Monat
und ich hab über Indien bestellt, da kostet es, glaub ich, 340 Indische Rupien. Indische,
ich weiß gar nicht, zu Euro, ja, meinetwegen. Da kostet es 3,86 Euro. Und das könnte sogar
3 Monate sein. Das könnte sogar 3 Monate sein. Warte mal, Indien YouTube Premium, mal kurz
gucken, mal kurz, mal kurz schenken. Naja. Da brauchst du ja nicht My Deals dafür, aber
vielleicht haben die es mal umgerechnet. Also ich hab das, was irgendwie 340, 340 Rupien
kosten. Also ich bezahle dann irgendwie für 3 Monate YouTube Premium, über Indien bezahle
ich dann irgendwie 350 oder so. Wie funktioniert das? Also da gibt es verschiedene Varianten.
Die einfachste Variante ist wahrscheinlich über ein kostenloses VPN, aber ich mach das
immer so. Ich geh zu Digital Ocean. Das kann man leider nicht über Hetzner machen. Wer
übrigens 20 Euro Startgut haben für die Hetzner Cloud braucht, weil er mal ein bisschen
sich mit virtuellen Servern austoben will, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner in den Chat, kriegt
ihr 20 Euro Startgut haben in meinem Gutscheincode. Aber leider kann man das nicht über die Hetzner
Cloud machen, weil man braucht einen Anbieter, die Server in Indien haben. Und Digital Ocean
hat ein Rechenzentrum in Bangalore. Ob da auch Banggood herkommt? So und das heißt man macht
sich eine VM, so mach ich das zumindest. Ich hab keinen Bock auf irgendwelche VPN Geschichten
oder sonst was. Ich miete mir einen Server bei Digital Ocean in Bangalore, installiere
mir auf dem Server einen Firefox, mach den Firefox über X-Forwarding auf, log mich ein
mit meinem Google Account, kauf YouTube Premium über Paypal und lösche den Server wieder.
Das dauert 5 Minuten. Und dann hast du YouTube Premium. Das bezahlst du dann über Paypal
in Google im Account und dann hast du für 3,50 Euro YouTube Premium. Guck mal wie teuer
der Krempel bei uns ist. Konfigurierst du den Server mit Ansible? Ne, da gibt es nichts
zu konfigurieren. Ich lass den so wie es ist, das einzige was ich mache ist Firefox installieren
und dann per X-Forwarding drauf, fertig. Nein, lohnt sich nicht. Finde ich, dass sich das
nicht lohnt. Du hast auf dem englischen Layout, gerade wenn du eine englische Tastatur hast,
du hast die, von der Beschriftung, du hast Klammern und sowas schon besser platziert,
aber ich finde die Umgewöhnung ist nicht wert im Endeffekt. Es gibt ja noch viel abgedrehtere
Tastaturlayouts zu programmieren. Lohnt sich? Nein, aus deiner Sicht vielleicht, ich seh
das anders. Also ich finde der Aufwand lohnt sich nicht englisches Tastaturlayout zu lernen
und zu programmieren. Aber kann jeder machen. Also ich finde es lohnt sich. Wie geht X-Forwarding?
Das ist relativ einfach. X-Forwarding geht, achso, ich weiß nicht ob ich euch das zeigen
kann. Kann ich euch zeigen, wie X-Forwarding geht. Es ist total einfach. Easy as fuck ist
X-Forwarding. So. Ich überleg grad, wo connecte ich mich denn mal von hier drauf. Wir können
Cloud-Server anlegen, nur dafür. Ich connecte mich einfach lokal, ist ja egal. So. Also
X-Forwarding, achso. So. Gut. Also. Du sagst einfach SSH-Y, connectest dich auf den Server,
wo du Firefox installiert hast. Und dann sagst du Firefox. Und dann gehts nicht, weil ich
X-Forwarding ausgeschaltet hab bei mir lokal. Aber mehr musst du nicht machen. Ich hab
einfach die Konfig nicht angepasst, das ist alles. Ich kann auf Raspberry Pi gehen, ja
stimmt. Äh. Was hab ich denn für ein Pi? Ist das ein Raspberry Pi? Äh. Scheiße. Das
ist doch aus dem Kopf jetzt nicht. Was hab ich denn mal für ein Raspberry Pi? Kannst
du dich auch Socksproxy PSSRK? Ja, kannst du auch machen. Äh. Warte mal, erst mal überlegen,
was hab ich denn für ein Raspberry Pi hier gerade am Start? Was ist das Ding von der
IP? 100? Vielleicht? Ah, das wär ja zu einfach. Ah, ich muss mal kurz in mein DHCP gucken.
Zack. Muss mal kurz in mein DHCP. DHCP Server Networks Leases. Hi, was haben wir denn da?
Aha, den gibt's nicht. Ach, das ist ja der Vierer. Ah, hier, den da. Perfekt. Für den
Drucker. Jawoll. So, verbindst dich auf den Raspberry Pi drauf. Ach, das ist OctoPie.
Das ist ein OctoPie standardmäßig für ein Passwort. Kein Schimmer. Meine Güte, äh.
Das scheint schwierig zu sein, hier was zu finden. Ok, dann nehm ich den jetzt. Ich hab
ja genug. Ich hab ja genug. Ok, ich hab Key-Authentifizierung und hab kein Key drauf. Leute, ich kann's
euch jetzt nicht zeigen. Ach, das ist ja nicht root, das ist Raspberry, ne? Nee, Pi, Pi-Add.
Das ist ja. Ah ja, wunderbar. Ok, Firefox. Ist da Firefox nicht drauf installiert? Chrome?
Auch nicht. Na dann. Dann installier ich jetzt einfach. Firefox. Was? Monkeys? Ah, so. Alles
klar. Alter. Das ist, das ist gegen mich. Ich kann's euch jetzt nicht zeigen. Das funktioniert
nicht. Das mag alles nicht. Will es jetzt auch nicht updaten, weil weiß was der dann
alles macht? Yep. Im Prinzip sagst du erst das H-Y. Y ist short, nein. Äh, ja doch,
genau, richtig. Also Y ist Abkürzung für X und das macht noch irgendwelche anderen
Dinger. So, weißt du was? Zeig euch, ich zeig euch, zeig euch das jetzt. Ich zeig
euch das jetzt. Ich mach das jetzt mit Hetzer Server. Login Hetzer. So. Das machen wir
jetzt. Nicht DNS. Konsole. New Server. Muss ich mich jetzt erstmal einloggen. Ach, jetzt
kommt wieder IP League. Fuck. Ich hab kein VPR. Nee, ich zeig's euch nicht. Was hat
eigentlich mein Raspberry Pi für Schmerzen, dass der hier nicht, nicht, äh, installieren
will, Firefox. Das ist, aber genauso wie ich's euch gezeigt hab, du machst SSH minus Y
und dann hast du, ich kann doch mal hier mal, ich mach einfach ETC, SSH, SSHD, config, forwarding.
Hier. Da war's doch irgendwo. Hier, allow. Yes. Yes. Restart, SSHD. Ok. SSH, localhost,
da machen wir das jetzt so. So, und ich hoffe jetzt funktioniert's, aber Firefox. Jawoll,
ja. Der Firefox läuft jetzt nicht bei mir lokal, der Firefox geht jetzt über die SSH
Verbindung und er zeigt das Fenster bei mir lokal an. Also dieser Server läuft jetzt
eigentlich auf dem anderen Rechner und ich hab, ich seh ihn bei mir lokal, so mach ich
das auch. Also sprich, ich hol mir sowas bei Digital Ocean in Indien und verbinde mich
mit x-forwarding drauf und dann ist gut. Der Kram kostet ja auch nicht viel, weil die
rechnen auch, ich glaub sogar minutlich ab. Ja. Pricing. Genau. Ja, da nimmt man einfach
irgendwie sowas. Am besten mit 4 CPU-Kernen, das ist ein Browser, das sich halbwegs halt
bedient. Ist egal, ob das 40€ im Monat kostet, weil ihr bezahlt. Am Endeffekt, in der Stunde
seid ihr locker durch. Es dauert 5 Minuten, wenn man weiß, was man macht. Bei mir auf
dem Pi kommt Error-No-Display-Environment-Specified. Hast du dich mit SSH-Y verbunden? Wenn das
nicht geht, installier x-Auth. Das kann sein, dass das fehlt, aber sollte eigentlich nicht
fehlen. Muss PSSH-Y drauf. Äh, guck mal, ob x-Auth installiert ist. Hier. Wenn ich
installier das mal und probier es nochmal. So. Was wir machen? Monk hast dir nix. Ich
hab grad 20 Minuten gebraucht für x-Forwarding, weil ich keine Kiste gefunden hab, wo ich
das zeigen konnte. Ja, dann ist ein, dann ist, sobald das da steht, ist eigentlich alles
richtig. Ja, dann musst du, dann guck mal in deine SSH-Config, ob x-Forwarding enabled
ist. Da muss das drinstehen, x11-Forwarding. Aber wenn nicht. Also wenn das gesetzt ist,
dann muss das funktionieren. Das ist eigentlich eines der unkomplizierten Sachen, die es so
gibt, x-Forwarding machen. So, und zumindest mach ich dann x-Forwarding über Digital Ocean,
Indian, VM und kauf mir Youtube Premium über Indian und bezahl dann 3,50 Euro für 3 Monate.
Viel besser als Youtube Premium hier zu kaufen. Easy. Dazu kann man eigentlich nur sagen.
So, leider kann man es glaube ich nicht einstellen, dass es automatisch verlängert. Sonst würde
ich das nämlich machen. Dann könnte ich mir den Krempel sparen. Wisst ihr, wisst ihr
was Big Brain Time wäre? Richtig Big Brain Time. Wir basteln eine Automatisierung dafür,
die mir Youtube Premium kauft. Also man müsste dann, man müsste, man müsste über die Digital
Ocean API eine VM erstellen, dann drauf einloggen und dann quasi dort den Browser fernsteuern.
Das ist mir aber glaube ich zu viel Aufwand für 5 Minuten klicken. Ja, das ist richtig.
Genau. Du musst SSHD noch neu starten, nachdem du die Option gesetzt hast. Aber ansonsten
wüsste ich nicht woran das liegen sollte. Warum überhaupt Youtube Premium? Denn zum
Beispiel, dass man keine Werbung sich angucken muss auf IOS. Auf IOS kannst du ja leider
nichts gegen Werbung machen. Weil Apple sich gedacht hat, es gibt keine alternativen Apps.
Nee. Ja, Bedgetime in eineinhalb Stunden. Was meinst du dann? Und ansonsten, ansonsten
juckt mich Youtube Premium eigentlich. Ich hab das nur wegen der Werbung. Bringt nix.
Zumindest nicht auf IOS. Oder ich müsste es mal wieder probieren. Hat jemand Piehole
im Einsatz? Und IOS, Youtube geht das mittlerweile wieder? Nee. Nee, dann muss ich es auch nicht
ausprobieren. Ja, Twitch geht auch nicht. Nee, Apple, also die sind ja da trickreich.
Du kannst dich ja da auch nicht irgendwie reinhängen oder so. Auf Android ist das alles
kein Problem. Auf Android hast du sowohl für Twitch als auch für Youtube alternative
Apps, wo das geht. Leider für Twitch nichts gescheites. Für Youtube gibt es ja ein paar.
Easy. Ja, und der IOS hast du halt gelitten. Aber ganz im Ernst, 3,50 Euro für 3 Monate,
das kann ich mir grad noch so leisten. Das ist okay. Warum geht eigentlich der Darkreader
nicht auf Youtube hier? Und warum ist das so eine Flashbang-Seite von Weiß auf Schwarz
und dann wird der Hochscore wieder Weiß? Twitch-Werbung kann man nicht gescheit blocken. Nee. Weiß
gar nicht, ob das Monkrat Toss ist, wenn man in einem Stream erzählt, wie man Twitch-Werbung
blockt. Meint ihr, das ist Toss? Das ist bestimmt Toss. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es gescheit
funktioniert aktuell. Es geht im Zweifelsfall nur mit customized Regex-Block-Regeln oder
irgendwelchen neuen Addons, die noch trickreicher sind. Was ist denn das? Sehr cube. Ja, das
geht aber nur. Das kannst du sideloaden, ne? Das kannst du sideloaden, aber sideloadete
Apps musst du ja alle einmal in der Woche neu sideloaden oder sowas. Da war doch was
bei IOS. Wenn du kein offizielles Developer-Zertifikat hast für das Gerät oder für dein Account,
das damit verknüpft ist, musst du alle 7 Tage neu sideloaden oder wie ist das nochmal?
Also Apple macht es einem echt schwer. Apple macht es einem wirklich schwer mit seinem
eigenen Gerät das machen zu können, was man will. Wobei, was als eigenes Gerät? Ich hab
das Ding ja immer noch von der Firma gesponsert bekommen. Also da will ich mich mal gar nicht
beschweren. Jetzt ist mal wieder der Zeitpunkt zu erwähnen, weil der Chat das immer so besonders
gerne hört. Es gibt außer Safari keine weiteren Browser auf IOS. Chrome und Firefox existieren
nicht auf IOS, so wie man denkt. Ja, genau, nur Browser. Oh, heute sind Big Brain Leute
am Start. Heute diskutiert keiner. Nein, bei Mac OS ist das nicht so. Bei Mac OS kannst
du noch normale Browser installieren. Aber unter IOS geht das nicht. Wenn du Chrome und
Firefox installierst, unter IOS ist das ein Reskin für Safari. Weil Apple sagt, ihr dürft
keine Browser anbieten für unsere Plattform, die nicht im Kern Safari verwenden. Und das
wäre ja auch gar nicht so schlimm, wenn Safari nicht so scheiße wäre mit den aktuellen Sachen.
Keine Web-Notifications, keine gescheite PWA-Unterstützung, Web-RTC-Zeug, was nicht richtig funktioniert.
Safari ist Paints-Champ. Auf dem Desktop nicht ganz so sehr, aber auf IOS richtiger Paints-Champ.
Deswegen funktioniert ja auch der Preis-Champ unter Safari nicht komplett. Web-Notifications,
guck mal, Web-Notifications funktionieren unter Android hier wunderbar. Unter IOS kannst
es vergessen, unter IOS kannst du dich nicht vom Preis-Champ benachrichtigen lassen. Und
Web-Notifications kannst du ja einfach ausschalten oder nur für bestimmte Seiten erlauben, das
ist ja nicht das Problem. Also man kann es ja nicht, nur weil manche Sachen nerven, wenn
man sie blöd einstellt, kann man ja nicht sagen, es ist komplett sinnlos. Doch der Preis-Champ
ist outdated. Ich habe aber keinen Bock mehr am Preis-Champ was zu machen. Du machst, nee,
nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht alles. Nicht alles. Ich habe ein paar Raspberry Pi Zeroes, ich
habe ein paar Raspberry Pis und ich habe ein paar ESP32. Ich habe bestimmt auch noch den
einen oder anderen ESP62 irgendwo. Einen Arduino habe ich aber nirgendwo. Meinung zu System
D. Ist es jetzt die nächste Triggerfrage zu sowie als Nachfolger von Meinung zu C++? Ganz
ehrlich, ich habe nichts gegen System D. Ein paar Dinger finde ich umständlich. Ich bin
zum Beispiel kein großartiger Fan Unit-Files versus normale Startup-Skripts. Da konnte man
immer noch ein paar ekliche Dinger drin machen, wenn sie mal notwendig waren. Dann hast du
noch nervige Sachen, dass du... Ich hatte letztens ein Problem mit System D. Kann mich
aber nicht mal richtig dran erinnern, was war denn das? Ich wollte irgendwas neu starten
lassen, weil es hängt. Genau, System D kann keine Health-Checks. Das hat mich letztens
genervt. Also du kannst mit System D keine Health-Checks machen, um zu gucken, zum Beispiel
ob ein Service noch richtig läuft und ihn da neu starten lassen. Klar, man könnte jetzt
sagen, das ist nicht die Aufgabe von System D, aber System D macht so ziemlich alles,
was nicht eigentlich die Aufgabe von einem Init-System ist. Warum sollte System D nicht
einen Health-Check haben? Du kannst es nur sehr umständlich machen und manche Sachen
gehen gar nicht. So ein Health-Check wäre tatsächlich ganz praktisch. Wenn du zum Beispiel
Web-Anwendungen hast, die ganz gerne mal hängen bleiben und man System D einfach keine Ahnung
einen Curl machen lassen könnte, einmal die Minute und wenn es fehlt schlägt, fünfmal
in Folge neu starten. Die Anwendung wäre ganz praktisch. Komplett daran das andere Thema
hast du eine bessere Ahnung wie Dual-Boot Windows 11, dann funktioniert, wenn ihr ein
Secure-Boot benutzen musst. Das geht doch bestimmt auszuhebeln, oder? Also manche Distributionen,
also ich weiß, dass Ubuntu sich mal, also Canonical hat mal dran gearbeitet, dass sie
Ubuntu gebootet bekommen mit Secure-Boot. Ich weiß nicht, wie da der aktuelle Stand
ist, Linux Secure-Boot. Also ich denke mal, man bekommt das zum Laufen. Ich denke man
bekommt das zum Laufen. Aber wisst ihr, was man machen könnte? Ich bin mal gespannt,
ob das funktioniert. Man könnte einfach sagen, scheiß auf den Windows-Bootloader und lässt
Krabb Windows starten, falls das funktioniert. Da gibt es, ich wette mit euch Leute, diese
Ankündigung, die es da jetzt gibt, die meisten Sachen werden wahrscheinlich mit ein paar
Patches oder Registry-Einträgen wieder zu deaktivieren sein. Gut, Registry im Bootmanager
gebe ich zu, war jetzt vielleicht ein dummer Vergleich, aber das wird alles, mal gucken.
Ihr wisst doch, wir sind nicht so heiß gegessen, wie es gekocht wird. Oh, da kommen die richtigen
Paint-Champ-Sprüche laufen, oder? Vorher hatte schon Amazon heiße Eisen im Feuer, aber
ich glaube, das wird nicht so wild, wie es jetzt aktuell aussieht. Nice. Also wie gesagt,
ich glaube nicht, wir warten, wir müssen es mal abwarten. Das kann durchaus sein, dass
die sagen, ok, jetzt wo Windows 10 nicht mehr supportet, dass die Leute umschwenken müssen,
dann forcieren wir irgendwelche Sachen. Ich bin ja der erste, der sagen würde, er verwendet
kein Windows mehr, wenn es gehen würde. Wie gesagt, es gibt halt immer noch genug Dinger,
da komme ich an Windows nicht vorbei. So, mein Vegas-Stells funktioniert glaube ich
unter, da muss ich mal kurz gucken, WineDB, lass mal kurz gucken, ne, wie ist das, ProtonDB,
da stehen glaube ich nur Games drin, mal gucken, ob Vegas mittlerweile, wahrscheinlich nicht,
ich würde Vegas aber im Leben auch nicht über Wine verwenden, weil es immer mehr Probleme
gibt. New Vegas, alles gut, Vegas Pro, Vegas Pro 13, zeig mal her. Läuft, Test Results,
Installer works good, na super, da bin ich ja beruhigt, dass der Installer funktioniert.
Windows does not work, just not run, wunderbar, perfekt. Garbage, latest rating Garbage,
ok, schauen wir mal wieder vorbei. Das ist übrigens auch das, was die ganzen Leute vergessen,
die hier immer nur die Spiele anführen, es gibt ja noch viele andere Windows Anwendungen,
auch bei Spielen ist das Ganze nicht so rosig, wie das immer hingestellt wird. Ich finde
es immer lustig, dass Linux-Fans dann mit mir als Linux-Fan drüber diskutieren, aber
es gibt doch ein paar Sachen, die sind gerade mit solchen Datenbanken relativ offensichtlich
zu widerlegen, dass es eben nicht alles rosig ist. So, also da tut sich nichts hier, Gold,
Vegas Pro 11 ist Gold, alles andere ist, Version 5, na super, also vergesst. Wie läuft, wie
ist denn Affinity, warte mal, da muss ich mal kurz gucken, Affinity Designer, wie läuft
das, Affinity Photo, Affinity Designer, Garbage, das funktioniert ja wunderbar, ja, gut, wunderbar,
also alle meine, also zwei der Programme, die ich mit am häufigsten verwende, laufen Garbage
einfach mal. Ich sag nicht, dass ich Photoshop brauche, ich bin zu dumm für Photoshop, das
einzige Modell, mit dem ich klar komme, ist Affinity Designer, das ist für so Kacknoobs
wie mich wunderbar, wenn man ein bisschen YouTube Thumbnails machen will, Affinity Designer,
damit komme ich klar, ne, das ist Mist, gerade so was ist in der VM Mist, gehen tut das bestimmt,
aber das ist hakeliger, als es sein muss, ich will ja meinen Workflow nicht total zerstören,
ne, das hat keinen Sinn, auch Pass Thru ist mehr Pains Champ, als man möchte eigentlich,
ne, vergessen, können wir vergessen, nächstes Jahr ist das Jahr des Linux, ich dachte dieses
Jahr war schon, oder besser gesagt, 2000, war nicht sogar 2010 das Jahr des Linux Desktop's,
ich glaube schon, so als Compiz auf, Leute, ich hab früher unter Ubuntu gedacht, Compiz ist der
Shit, der Linux auf dem Desktop zum Durchbruch verhelfen wird und das war auch mega geil Compiz,
die Würfel, Wobbly Windows und alles, leider gibt es das nicht mehr, die versuchen jetzt irgendwie,
die ganze Linux Distribution versuchen, Desktop Linux Zeug so nach Mac aussehen zu lassen,
die sollen lieber Effekt Overload Compiz-Stalls machen, wie geiler, ja ich weiß, vieles,
vieles kannst du zusätzlich noch machen, aber Compiz war das beste, da sind Fenster abgefackelt
beim zumachen und so, nicht beste, Videos nur noch mit FFmpeg bearbeiten, ja FFmpeg kann zwar viel,
ich weiß, dass das eine Kappa HD Message ist, aber FFmpeg kann viel, aber du kannst mit FFmpeg halt
nicht ernsthaft Videos bearbeiten, nee, nee, achso, ja, es ist immer noch kaputt, ich hab
immer noch nicht ausgetauscht oder dran rumgewackelt, weil aktuell ist Sommer und ich brauch das außer
das warme Wasser eh nicht, Moment, das mach ich jetzt nicht auf, wo gibt es die Spezial-Effekte
noch, zeig mal her, ja, genau, genau, diese Dinger, Compiz-Stalls, beste, so muss das sein,
Wobbly-Windows, wir sehen du kriegst das bestimmt in der VM so ein schlechtes Performance wie das
hat, Wobbly-Windows, jawoll, ja Moment, Videos automatisch schneiden ist das eine, aber Videos
bearbeiten, ja, also Overlays machen, Subscribed-Messages einfügen, das machst du mit FFmpeg nicht,
Überblend-Effekte an der richtigen Stelle und nee, nee, nee, nee, und welche Videos sollen
dort überhaupt automatisch geschnitten werden, ich glaube KDE hat da teilweise die Sachen von
Compiz übernommen, aber nicht alles, du musst dir mal die KDE, ich hab jetzt nix wo wir das
vergleichen können, aber guck mal in die KDE-Settings rein, dann guck dir mal in alten
Screenshots von Ubuntu, von dem alten Compiz-Manager an, wir sehen du konntest hier grade so übertrieben
viel Schwachsinn einstellen, das geht in KDE nicht mehr, die haben ein paar Sachen daraus
genommen, ja, so aufzeige ich mal ein paar Effekte, genau, Compiz-Stells, auf gehts,
da ist der ganze Kram, genau, das kannst du in KDE nicht alles machen, du hattest so viel
abgedrehtes Zeug, Wobbly-Windows, der wichtigste Effekt überhaupt natürlich, ja genau das,
der Würfel und so, beste, beste, ja, das geht glaube ich mit KDE auch noch mit dem Würfel,
CAC 4D, guck, ja so muss das sein, und dann auch random einstellen, dann auch random
einstellen, dass du das jedes Mal, wenn du das Fenster auf und zu machst, einen anderen
randomized Effekt nimmst, beste, ja so muss das sein, leider gibt es, es gibt einen Compiz-Fork,
aber der so wirklich aktiv entwickelt wird der auch nicht, es ist auf jeden Fall das
beste gewesen, exzellent, dann 24 Monate Alper-Subscription hier, oder bei den, achso, bei den, bei den,
bei was bist du in Führung, bei den gegifteten Subs, Massive, jetzt schauen, im Dashboard
können wir ein paar Leute übersehen heute, Mario XCB, Dankeschön, für den Sub hab ich
nicht gesehen, der Spack-Hack auch am Start, Korni14, auch subscripted, subscripted, alter,
subs, das fällt mir neu, irgendjemand hatte mal in einem Vortrag, da musste ich, da musste
ich real life, real life kecken, das weiß ich noch, hat in irgendeinem Vortrag, wollte
der Subscriber sagen und hat gemerkt, es ist ein deutscher Vortrag und hat dann gesagt,
subscribieren, und da hab ich schon so innerlich, wahrscheinlich nicht nur innerlich, aber den
hier gemacht, ja, subscribieren, alter, also das ist vielleicht ein gültiges Wort, keine
Ahnung, aber auf jeden Fall nichts, was man normalerweise verwendet, subscribieren, alles
klar, ja, achja, ich wollte mir mit euch das Developer-Surfer mal in Ruhe angucken von,
von Jetplains, genau, also was mich überrascht hat, ist folgendes, das hab ich euch, glaub
ich, das letzte Mal schon kurz gezeigt, ich mach mal kurz den Dark Mode raus, Achtung,
Flashbang, bam, mach mal kurz den Dark Mode rein, nee, nee, ich mach den Dark Mode rein,
das hältst du nicht aus, aber du erkennst es nicht richtig, egal, was ich euch zeigen
wollte, erkennste, was ich sehr spannend fand, hier drinnen ist das hier, Operating System,
auf den entwickelt wird, 61% Windows, wundert mich nicht, ich mein, das ist garantiert multiple,
also du konntest garantiert mehrere selekten, sonst kommst du ja nicht über 100%, aber
trotzdem, man sieht, dass Windows für technische Sachen einfach kacke ist und die 61% die Windows
verwenden, die machen das wahrscheinlich auch zumindest 30% davon, gar nicht freiwillig,
sondern weil ihr Chef der Meinung ist, er arbeitet auch mit Windows, das heißt die Programmierer
sollen gefälligst auch mit Windows arbeiten, kennt ihr so Leute, die sagen also nach dem
Motto, also, äh, wenn ich das verwende, dann könnt ihr das auch verwenden, ich hatte damit
noch nie Probleme, das ist doch für euch bestimmt und ihr seid ja Techniker, ihr habt damit doch
bestimmt noch weniger Probleme, das sind dann die richtig, richtig 3-Hat Aussagen, bei uns
ist auch lustig, da wollen sie ja auch mittlerweile immer mal wieder, dass wir Windows Notebooks
kriegen und ich hab das letzte Mal gefragt, ok, könnt ihr mir Rider installieren und
es gibt ein offenes Ticket, das ist seit 3 Monaten offen, bei der, wie heißen die bei
uns eigentlich, bei denen die Softwareverwaltung machen, ich hab gesagt, ich hab ganz viele
Sachen in C-Sharp, ich brauch eine ordentliche Idee, dass ich da weiter dran programmieren
kann, ergänzen kann, Bug fixen kann, sonst Neuentwicklung machen kann, installiert mir
mal Rider und die kriegen das seit 3 Monaten nicht hin, also, das könnte natürlich auch
an unseren Leuten liegen, ja, was hast du für eine Distribution auf deinem Arbeits-PC,
ich hab meinen Jaro i3, im Prinzip hab ich auf der Arbeit das hier, was ich hier auch
hab, sieht auch genauso aus, hab ich auch mal das ASCII-Quarium auf zur Entspannung,
im Prinzip sieht mein Arbeits-Desktop genauso aus wie hier, ich hab die Konfix ja mal nach
GitHub gesüngt vor einer Weile, ist nicht top aktuell, aber im Prinzip kommt es noch
hin, was unter anderem steht, ich glaub, das ist nicht aufgeschlüsselt, naja, das sind
da wahrscheinlich so Sachen wie Solaris oder sowas, oder, tja, BSD vielleicht, vielleicht
hat irgendjemand einen BSD, auf dem er entwickelt, warst du nicht Wishlist Studio Code Fan, doch,
aber man macht nicht alles in Wishlist Studio Code, es gibt Sachen, die sind in anderen
Sachen besser aufgehoben, du möchtest zum Beispiel kein Java, Kotlin, C-Sharp oder
sonst was in Wishlist Studio Code programmieren, auch Go ist nicht so schön, wenn man, obei,
Go, doch, Go ist okay, das stimmt, die haben nämlich den eigentlichen Bug gefixt, den
ich mal vor jahrelang hatte, dass wenn man nämlich Interop mit C macht, dass dann, also
wenn du oben diese C-Go Definition reinschreibst, dann ist nach ein paar Minuten das Wishlist
Studio Go Plugin abgekackt und hat die Auto-Completion immer funktioniert, ich glaub,
das haben sie gefixt, ja, also C-Sharp in Wishlist Studio Code ist nicht schön, es
ist brauchbar, weil Microsoft halt ihr Standard-Toolzeug da mitbringt, aber es ist nicht, macht nicht
viel Spaß, hey, was hältst du vom Framework Laptop, ich weiß nicht, was der Framework
Laptop ist, ja, aber das finde ich interessant, ich vermute mal, dass das hier BSD ist und
klar, man kann, man kann verschiedene Betriebssysteme auswählen, frame.work, was hat denn die Domain
wohl gekostet, Framework Laptop ist now shipping, okay, dünner, leichtes Notebook, was ist
mit was Bestand haben soll, aha, okay, was macht das jetzt aus, Framework Laptop 99 Dollar
und das ist vom Preis her absolut in Ordnung, wenn da was Gescheites drin ist, sieht aus
wie ein Notebook, oben ist eine Kamera oder so und komische Knappen, ah, das ist einer,
wo man selbst dran rumbasteln kann, warum genau sollte ich am Notebook selbst rumbasteln,
ist das für den Fall der Fehler, dass er kaputt geht und ich ihn reparieren muss oder
was ist der Hintergedanke davon, also was ist der, warum sollte ich mir den kaufen, Linux
Support, okay, naja, gut, das gibt es ja bei vielen, indirekt, weil halt die Hardware,
die drin ist, unterstützt wird, ich finde es viel interessanter, was der Typ gerade
Hackerman macht, das muss ich mir angucken, ich brauche das Bilding groß, Leute, Image
Newtap, was ist das, Struct, ist das C, sieht man in Clue, ja, das ist C, oder es ist C++,
was ja nach C aussieht, ah ne, guck mal da, C tatsächlich, C und nicht C++, das finde
ich nicht schlecht, da kannst du dir dann auch überlegen, was du da genau reinmachst,
ja von der Idee her sicherlich nicht verkehrt, also die Preisfrage ist natürlich, wie schlägt
sich das preisleistungstechnisch gegen einen normalen Laptop so in der ähnlichen Liga,
klar, es wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen teurer sein, aber ist die Frage, wie viel
teurer, also ich denke mal die meisten Leute sind bereit vielleicht ein Drittel mehr zu
bezahlen, aber dann ist aber auch die Schmerzgrenze erreicht, ok, wo kann man preordern, also will
ich nicht ordnen, ich will mal einen zusammenklicken und gucken, was es kostet, ah hier, achso,
es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man ihn fertig geliefert bekommt oder die Einzelteile, ok,
sagen wir mal fertig geliefert, wird nicht nach EU geschippt, das macht nichts, ich will
nur sehen, was es kostet, Koggers, ey das sieht ein bisschen aus, muss man ihn lassen,
sieht ein bisschen aus wie im Apple Store, es ist auch basic, BAM, E7, E6, wer kommt
also 8G Leute, also ich meine damit nicht den Nachfolger von 5G, sondern 8GB, also 8GB
ist ja outdated, und 256G kommst du ja hinten und vorne nicht hin, aber noch fetter, jawoll,
kann man gar nicht, kann man gar nicht selecten, achso, aber ok, Linux Support ist tatsächlich
ein Vorteil, obwohl es jetzt hier der Vorteil gegenüber, sagen wir, ich gehe in den Online
Shop und order mir das Teil, das habe ich nicht so genau verstanden, es ist einfacher
zu reparieren auf jeden Fall, ja aber, du kannst bis zu 6 SSDs nachrüsten, alter, ok
gehen wir mal zu, hallo, do it yourself Edition, ich glaube, ich habe die Website kaputt gemacht,
ja, guck mal, das ist eine Single Page Application, die den Zurückknopf im Browser nicht richtig
handelt, direkt geprickt, also was kann man hier auswählen, ok, CPU, das reicht mir ehrlich
gesagt, der kleine, 46G, BAM, also, oh, da haben wir irgendwas, WiFi, non pro, pro, ich
weiß nicht, was der Unterschied ist, bring your own, wie das geht nicht, doch man, das
ist noch beschäftigt, das ist jetzt so schnell, bring your own, storage, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
Terabyte reicht, aber Terabyte sollte schon sein, ich finde das eigentlich, das, das
macht, was soll das sagen, ah, das ist Kaution, ne, nicht Kaution, wie nennt man das so, sodass
nicht die Leute sinnlos vorbestellen, die gar nicht wollen, der Chat ist vor dem Preis,
also, hier Chat, so Anzahlung, ja, scheint mir ganz in Ordnung zu sein, man muss es
halt selbst zusammenbauen, ne, ich bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt, es gab ja schon
ein paar Versuche, so modulare Smartphones und sonst was zu machen, hat alles nicht so
gut funktioniert, mal gucken, ob es damit was wird, genau, Anzahlung meine ich, ja,
nicht Kaution, Kaution ist das, wenn man Monkathos war und in Knast muss und dann temporär wieder
raus darf, jetzt, jetzt, zeig mir Twitch den Fallout Channel, ja, was soll ich sagen,
ich bin auch dafür, dass Twitch den Channel mir empfiehlt, ihr sollt mal Twitch anschreiben
und sagen, jetzt hört mal auf, irgendwie Indie Fox und, wobei, ne, sorry, Indie Fox
ist ja gebannt, ihr sollt lieber anstatt Poolgrills meinen Stream empfehlen, bin ich
auch dafür, können wir machen, ja, finde ich nicht schlecht, macht eigentlich, macht
eigentlich ganz guten Eindruck, das Teil, Max, Max im HotTube, ja, irgendwann vielleicht,
irgendwann HotTube Stream, nach Face Reveal und ihr wisst ja, Face Reveal gibt es bald
bei einer Million Abos, auf YouTube, oder auf Twitch ist mir eigentlich egal, eine Million
Abos, wird es eh nicht geben, insofern, easy, Face Reveal war doch schon, noch nie, noch
nie, wo ich gesagt hab, Face Reveal, ich wurde schon zufällig ab und zu mal Revealed, ja,
aber noch nie, wo ich gesagt hab, Face Reveal, ist der, ist der on, ist der on, nein, ist
nicht on, eines der alten Unbox, da auch, da auch, jetzt gibt es so viele Sachen, wo
ich schon mal Revealed wurde, auf irgendwelche Events, wo ich mal durchs Bild gelaufen bin,
wo es keiner gecheckt hat, dann Unboxing Videos, alles mögliche, so, also genau, das wollte
ich mir jetzt ja mal mit euch angucken, also JetBrains hat eine Umfrage gemacht, äh, unter
31.743 Developers, Developers, Developers, welcher Streamer seht ihr ähnlich, da gibt
es eine ganz klare Antwort, wenn ich das Emote finde, Dance Gaming, also ich muss sagen,
also wenn ich mir Dance Gaming so angucke und mich so angucke, da ist, das sieht sich
doch schon ziemlich ähnlich, ja, ich, er hat in letzter Zeit ja auch deutlich weniger
Haare bekommen, also ich würde sagen, ich hab sogar noch ein bisschen mehr Haare als
Dance Gaming, aber ansonsten finde ich, äh, und vom Bart her muss ich sagen, sieht auch
dieses Total Biscuit Bild mir relativ ähnlich, das könnte, also, wenn ich nicht wüsste,
dass es Total Biscuit ist, könnte, könnte das auch, könnte ich das auch, wenn die Auflösung
schlechter wäre, könnte ich das auch sein. So, also, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau,
sie haben eine Umfrage gemacht unter ungefähr 32.000 Developer, äh, gut, Countries ist jetzt,
ist jetzt wurscht, sind ein paar Sachen drin, die ich echt ganz interessant fahre, das wundert
uns glaube ich alle nicht, dass JavaScript die beliebteste Sprache ist, oder wundert
uns irgendjemand, sagt irgendjemand, ah, ich hätte eher Cobol erwartet anstatt JavaScript,
ich glaube sagt keiner, also ja, das war, es war klar, äh, JavaScript ist die beliebteste
Sprache gefolgt, vermute ich mal von Python, weil das ist auch beides saubermäßig beliebt.
Das stimmt, ja, die meist, die meist benutzte. Achso, die meisten Leute gezwungen sind.
So, äh, Python ist more popular als, als Java, oder Java, wir müssen das ja mal Jira, Java,
muss das ja cool aussprechen, ich hab vorhin auch wieder John Ubuntu nicht richtig ausgesprochen,
ich meine natürlich Jubantu, so, ähm, okay, Top 5 Languages sind, ah ne, die 5 Top Sprachen,
wo Leute gerne ihre Software hin, äh, umprogrammieren würden, also Sprache, wenn sie Sprache wechseln
würden, das ist Go, Kotlin, TypeScript, Python und Rust, gut, Kotlin kann ich verstehen,
man macht freiwillig schon was in Java, Java ist halt einfach Paints Champ, wenn ich irgendwas
in, auf JVM Basis machen müsste, würde ich das auch auf jeden Fall in Kotlin machen,
das einzige, was ich bisher jemals auf JVM gemacht hab, ist, äh, Groovy, aber auch nicht
viel, TypeScript kann ich auch verstehen, Python kann ich auch verstehen, Rust ist ne
typische Sprache, wo jeder sagt, er würde gerne auf Rust umziehen und wenn er dann anfängt
auf Rust umzuziehen, äh, umzuziehen, dann denkt er sich dann, ich bin zu dumm für Rust
und bleib bei der anderen Sprache, macht keiner, genau, das ist so, Wunsch zur Realität ist
Rust und Go hat auch so seine Dinger, wo viele glaub ich, weiß nicht, äh, zu blauigisch
rangehen, also Go hat auch Eigenheiten, die, mal gucken wir mal, ob es Generics in Go gibt,
dann wird einiges besser, hoffe ich mal, ja, es sind einige Sachen merkwürdig in Go, also
wie gesagt, der fehlende Generic Support ist doof, äh, dann diese, diese, wie soll ich
das beschreiben, so diese Sache mit Error Handling, dass du es eigentlich mit Return
Code machst, aber dann doch sowas wie Try Catch mit Panic hast, ähm, dass es ganz furchtbar
eklig ist zu checken, also syntaktisch eklig, ob ein Key in einem Dictionary drin ist in
Go, oder ich, vielleicht finde ich ihn auch nur ich hässlich, und eine persönliche Sache,
die ich nicht mag an Go, ist, dass Go der Meinung ist, dass Go der Meinung ist, sowas
machen zu müssen, wer hat sich das ausgedacht, das ist nicht Phifat, das ist einfach nur
Woodface, ich weiß viele mögen das, viele mögen das, ich mag das nicht, für mich,
also das könnte ich mir noch gefallen lassen, das, das, das meinetwegen, meinetwegen so,
aber ich persönlich bevorzuge ja den hier, aber ich bin auch jemand, der mag 2 Spaces
als Einrückung anstatt 4, Leute was sagt ihr, 4 Spaces oder 2 Spaces? Keine Spaces,
äh, also das heißt ihr macht quasi rechtseitige, rechtsbündige Einrückung oder? Ja ob Tap
oder Spaces, Tap werte ich mal als 4 Spaces, vom Abstand ungefähr, mir geht es nur um
die Anzeige, also mir ist egal, ob es 2 Spaces oder 4 Spaces sind bei Tap, also Tap würde
ich jetzt sagen zählt als 4 Spaces, also mir ist egal ob Spaces oder Tap, mir geht es
um den Abstand, ich mag den Abstand von 2 Spaces, genau das ist bei mir auch die Sache,
ich mag 2 Spaces, weil wenn du sowas wie C Sharp programmierst, da hattest du lange
Zeit halt so Sachen wie Namespaces Einrückung, Klasseneinrückung, das ist jetzt alles ein
bisschen besser geworden in den letzten Sprachen, aber halt noch nicht richtig nice und da kannst
du einfach Einrückung sparen, ja, also ich mag 2 Spaces, so, also das fand ich dann
hier eigentlich ganz spannend, sowas sind einfach stehen geblieben, also wie gesagt
zu Rust werden sie nie mehr kreieren, haben sie das immer noch vor, ok 3 Spaces ist natürlich
dann, warum nicht einfach 1,5 Spaces, wie wäre es eigentlich damit, warum haben wir
eigentlich schon nicht halbe Einrückung erfunden, ich glaube ich sollte mal den eigenen Editor
programmieren, ne, ne, Leute wir programmieren einen Wishful Studio Code Addon, keine Ahnung
ob man das mit dem Addon machen kann, der 1,5 Spaces Einrückung machen kann, es gibt ja
sogar halbe Leerzeichen, stimmt, es gibt ja Unicode mäßig alles mögliche, so also
Top Languages, die Entwickler 2021 gelernt haben, JavaScript, Python, TypeScript, Java
Go, ja das wundert mich auch nicht, JavaScript klar, Python auch immer weiter am Aufsteigen
gerade an der Uni oder eben was Machine Learning angeht, TypeScript auch mit JavaScript, viele
fangen ja mit JavaScript an und sagen dann irgendwann, hey ich probiere mal TypeScript
und steige da nie wieder zurück um auf JavaScript, weil im Prinzip ist ja TypeScript, JavaScript
bloß mit mehr, also JavaScript ist gültiges TypeScript, aber TypeScript ist nicht gültiges
JavaScript, ja und Go, gut, Go kann ich verstehen, Go hat einfach so unglaublich viele Tutorials
und Sachen, man kommt gut rein, Ruby, Ruby Objective C und Scala, oh, innerhalb der letzten
5 Jahre sind die viel unbeliebter geworden, tja, gut Scala kann ich verstehen, Scala,
achso, jetzt hat jemand vorhin gefragt, ob sich es lohnt, das englische Tastaturlayout
zu lernen, ja wenn du Scala programmierst, dann lohnt sich das, also Scala besteht ja
im Prinzip nur aus Klammern, nicht dass ich das jetzt verwechsel mit Erlang oder so, warte
mal, Code Examples, ja doch, es besteht aus ziemlich vielen Klammern, aber wobei geht
da eigentlich, irgendwie hatte ich im Hinterkopf, dass Scala total viele Klammern hat, Lisp,
ja Lisp ist ja noch das Allerschlimmste, wisst ihr was das Schlimmste ist an Klammern, Emacs
und Lisp, Example, guckt euch das mal an, also wer sich den Shit antut, weiß ich auch
nicht, guckt euch das mal an, das meinen die ernst, ja, guckt euch das an, guckt, ja,
und das lustige ist, wisst ihr warum die Lisp damals in Emacs eingebaut haben, weil
die gesagt haben, ach nee, C verstehen die normalen User ja nicht, die sollen das gefälligst
in Lisp programmieren, als wäre der Shit einfacher zu verstehen als C Funktion, unverstissbar,
also gut, gut Emacs ist ja eh fast schon in der Bedeutungslosigkeit verschwunden 2021,
gibt es noch jemand bei euch, der Emacs verwendet, nee, ok aber das verstehe ich, Ruby ist halt
total aus der Mode gekommen, Ruby ist wie gesagt, ne was sie schafft, meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache,
aber Ruby hat einen riesen Aufstieg gehabt mit Rails und das ist ja die letzten Jahre
über Steinberg abgegangen und Ruby hat es nicht geschafft so wirklich ne eigene, so
ein herausstechendes Merkmal zu haben, dass die Leute gesagt haben, hey wir verwenden
jetzt Ruby anstatt keine Ahnung, Java Skript oder Paaßen, also ich kann es nachvollziehen,
wenn Ruby ne super Sprache ist, Ruby 3 kam raus, hat angeblich vieles verbessert, ich
hab es bis heute nicht ausprobiert, weil Ruby mittlerweile so unbedeutend ist, ich mag
zwar Ruby, aber man kann es vergessen mittlerweile, Objective C wundert mich nicht, das war ja
in der heutigen Zeit, also das war ja in den letzten paar Jahren bis jetzt in die heutige
Zeit eigentlich nur auf Apple irgendwie relevant und die haben jetzt, na wie heißt es, Swift
am Start, ich weiß gar nicht wie das ist, ob es immer noch Sachen gibt, die man nicht
mit Swift machen kann, wo man Objective C für braucht, aber es ist verschwindend gering
auf jeden Fall, gut Skala, ja gut, wer sich das mal gegeben hat weiß ich eh nicht, ok
faster scrolling languages ist Paaßen, TypeScript, Kotlin, SQL und Go, Paaßen und TypeScript
wundert mich nicht, Kotlin wundert mich auch nicht, ich würde auf jeden Fall das immer
vorziehen als Java zu machen, ja ich, zwei Monate Subscription, Dankeschön für den
Sub, exquisite, Sub, SQL braucht man immer, ja und Go ist halt beliebt, weil Go viele Tutorials
hat und viele Leute mit Go halt auch anfangen, das wundert mich auch nicht, dass das drin
ist, viele Cloud Sachen sind ja auch in Go programmiert, ok, ein Großteil der Leute,
die bei einer Umfrage teilgenommen haben, entwickeln Web Anwendung, das Backend für
Web Anwendung, das finde ich interessant, hätte eigentlich gedacht die meisten Leute
sind irgendwie, gut wir sind ja nicht auf Stack Overflow, auf Stack Overflow sind die meisten
wahrscheinlich Frontend Java Script Stells, Gkanalshu, Stufe 1, huge Username, oh der
Hype Train nähert sich Leute, ich sehe es schon, wir werden gleich wieder gescampt von
Twitch, gebated, Scam Train ist unterwegs, Crystal kenne ich, Crystal hat das Problem
das es nicht unter Windows läuft, auch sonst ziemlich in Nischensprache ist, wenn das das
letzte Mal lief das nicht unter Windows, also Programming Languages, was ist besonders beliebt,
Java Script wissen wir, HTML, CSS, logisch, jetzt kommen natürlich die ersten wieder
Sachen, null, warum ist HTML in der Umfrage, aber ich kann es verstehen, das ist halt was,
was viele Leute den Tag über machen und scheiß drauf, ob es eine Programmiersprache ist oder
nicht, wir schreiben es ja sogar selbst, es geht einfach darum, was viele Leute in ihrer
IDE so den ganzen Tag machen und da ist HTML, CSS wahrscheinlich vorne dabei, SQL, logisch,
wobei ich es immer noch erstaunlich finde, dass so viele Leute SQL von Hand schreiben,
wenn man nicht totalen Mist macht mit seinem DB, Mapper, Framework, wie auch immer man
es jetzt nennen mag, dann geht es doch eigentlich mittlerweile, ich meine du kannst natürlich
auch sagen, wenn du jetzt verwendest EF Core oder sowas, weil wir jetzt gerade bei C Sharp
sind, du kannst ja auch dumme Sachen machen, wie erst irgendwie die alle ID's rausholen,
dann eine Schleife und dann damit andere Sachen abfragen, anstatt einen Joint zu machen,
du kannst Mist bauen, aber ich frage mich woran das liegt, dass so viele Leute noch
SQL von Hand programmieren.
Was total viele Stellenanzeigen suchen nach Entwickler, HTML, CSS, ja Frontend Sachen
sind beliebt, aber ich würde halt sagen zukunftsfähig, ich meine klar, du wirst in Zukunft auch
Webentwickler brauchen, aber Webentwickler hat so von allen, ist meine Einschätzung
nach ja, so die geringsten Geldaussichten, also da gibt es einfach so viele und ich habe
die dumme Vermutung, aber das kann sich auch als komplett falsch rausstellen, dass über
mittlere Zukunft Webentwickler weniger werden, die man braucht.
Ey mal gucken, mal gucken, ich mache eigentlich mittlerweile ganz gerne eben bei ein bisschen
Javascript Zeug.
So also Java ist das nächste gute Business-Stell, Shellscripting Languages wundert mich jetzt
auch nicht, vieles ist halt einfach mal schnell in einem Shellscript zusammen gewurstet und
um verschiedene Sachen miteinander zu verbinden ist ein Shellscript super, irgendwelche automatischen
Teststarten oder irgendwelche Init-Sachen in einem Repo, dass du sagen kannst, hey du
hast da einen Checkout-Script oder du hast irgendwie einen Skript, was dir was aufsitzt,
das verstehe ich, das ist damit einfach easy gemacht, ein paar Zeilen Shellscript ist meistens
für kleine Sachen einfacher als da jetzt irgendwie Big-Brain-Python-Zeug zu basteln
oder sowas, ist GitLab CE auch Shellscripting, ich vermute mal, dass du da Shellscript ausführen
kannst, ansonsten muss ich dir ehrlich sagen, ich habe GitLab CE nie wirklich großartig
verwendet, keine Ahnung, Script versus Makefile, ne das kommt drauf an, was man machen will,
Makefile finde ich halt schwarze Magie, denn Shellscript hat den Vorteil, dass wenn man
eine ordentliche Sprache verwendet, also wir reden jetzt nicht von C++, sondern irgendeine
ordentliche Sprache, wo du einen ordentlichen Package-Manager dabei hast, wo du ordentliche
Fehlermeldungen bekommst und ordentliche Tools dabei hast und ordentliche Configs hast,
dann kannst du halt den Shellscript in ein Repo legen, sagen wir für irgendwie Test-Deployment
oder sowas, dann führst du das aus, dann baut er dir das Programm zusammen und schiebt
das per SSH irgendwo hin und startet dann den Service neu, das sind 5 Zeilen Shellscript,
das ist easy, kann jeder machen, brauchst dann bloß dein SSH Key an der richtigen Stelle,
für sowas ist halt ein Shellscript einfach praktisch, da muss man es nicht übertreiben,
klar kann man jetzt wieder sagen, ja wie sieht es aus, eh, continuous delivery, Pipeline,
sonst was, wenn ich einfach nur mal was schnell ausprobieren will, manchmal ist ein Shellscript,
also die oldschool Variante mit einem Shellscript auf irgendeinen Test-Server was zu kopieren,
den Service neu zu starten und dann mal im Browser zu refreshen, die einfache Variante
als da jetzt irgendwelche komischen Big Brain Deployment Pipelines aufzusetzen.
C++ ist eine ordentliche Sprache, das habe ich nicht gesagt, ich habe gesagt C++ ist
keine ordentliche Sprache, ich habe gesagt eine ordentliche Sprache also nicht C++, C++
hat ja nichts, was eine ordentliche Sprache ausmacht, doch das ist eine super Fehlermeldung,
das ist die allerbeste, genauso C++ Fehlermeldung finde ich gut, ja, da weißt du Bescheid, aber
ich will jetzt nicht von C++ anfangen, weil wenn ich von C++ anfange, dann wisst ihr
Leute, dann hören wir so schnell nicht mehr auf über C++ zu flamen, C++ in der Schule,
ja mein Beileid.
Ein schönes Beispiel, komm wo wir jetzt dabei sind, schönes Beispiel, wo ich immer drüber
kecken muss ist das hier, ich habe es hier gerade gefunden deswegen, schönes Beispiel
wo ich immer drüber kecken muss ist folgendes, was tut es, was macht es?
Ich weiß mittlerweile geht es einfacher, aber auch erst seit C++ 20 glaube ich, es kompiliert,
das funktioniert, das funktioniert wirklich, ihr müsst es nicht wissen was das macht,
das ist bescheuert einfach nur so Dinge, also gucken wir mal weiter, es ist obvious, ja
total klar was das macht, das ist genauso obvious was das macht, wie das letzte ffmpeg
Kommando was wir hier haben, ja, also das finde ich auch total obvious, ffprobv error select
stream v0 count packets show entries stream nb read packets of csv gleich p gleich 0 und
dann das gif, das finde ich auch total offensichtlich, dass das Kommando so sein muss, also wie könnte
man jetzt auch denken, dass das Kommando irgendwie anders aussehen muss, voll obvious halt, wenn
du deine eigene Programmiersprache releasen würdest, wie würdest du sie nennen, cute chat,
keck++ würde ich es auf gar keinen Fall nennen, ich würde es cute chat, oder, oder, ich würde
darauf setzen, dass die ganzen weebs die Programmiersprache lernen und berühmt machen, ich würde sie
irgendwie nennen, meweep, me-spam-mod-bucker-if-ban, cute++, keine Ahnung, ich würde mir wirklich
nicht irgendwas big-brainiges ausdenken, keine Ahnung, mir fällt gerade nichts gescheites
ein, hentai-sharp, oh das ist eine gute Idee, dann hast du auf jeden Fall schon mal die Benutzergruppe
gesichert, ja, ayayascript, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht, ok, also, ok, ok, also
als Shellscripting so leuchtet mir voll und ganz ein, dass das noch beliebt ist, das ganze
gefolgt von php, wenn man das da wieder cool aussprechen will, wo lang, da würde ich
mir irgendwas überlegen, aber zum Glück muss ich keine Programmiersprache entwickeln,
denn meine Programmiersprache hätte garantiert Memory Leaks und ich hoffe nicht, dass irgendwann
man da mit einem Auto steuern will oder sowas, dann ist vorbei, so, was haben wir da sonst
noch, gut, php verstehe ich auch, php leuchtet ein, php ist halt immer noch webseitentechnisch
angesagt und auch wenn viele jetzt sagen, max jetzt übertreibt man nicht, ich muss sagen,
das was ich in letzter Zeit, ich habe in letzter Zeit nichts mit php gemacht, aber das letzte
mal, die letzten paar Sachen, die ich so gesehen habe, auch mal in ein paar Konferenztalks
und so von php, mit den passenden Frameworks, ist gar nicht so schlecht, ist echt in Ordnung,
aber relax days, komme ich jetzt bei Rick Astley raus, Moment, die sieht aus, als macht
die gleich Yogaübung oder sowas hier vor der Cam, mit dem unbequemen Stuhl, ok, das
ist PainsChamp, also schauen wir mal was PainsChamp ist, deine Aufgaben sind, meinst du das Video
ist PainsChamp oder die Stellenanzeige ist PainsChamp, Neuentwicklung von Backend Applikation
mit PHP Storm, ok, sie verwenden schon mal eine gescheite IDE, da bin ich ja schon mal
in Ordnung, Analyse der Anforderungen im Fachbereich sowie Anpassung, ok, Arbeiten mit einer Microservice
Architektur und sichern, ok, stetiger Austausch mit Frontend Team zur Gewähr, ok, ein bisschen
mehr zu dem was man eigentlich macht, wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt, das Video ist Cringe,
ok, gucken wir uns gleich an, damit überzeugst du uns, Fachinformatik, Analyse Entwickler,
Bachelor Informat, blablabla, Fortgeschrittene PHP Kenntnisse, Bündnisse, Dockers, Sage,
ee, Team Foundation, wer verwendet denn das noch, MonkaS, Team Foundation, Continuous Delivery,
Jira, Confluence, MySQL, Symfony, Doctrine, braucht man nicht, ihr wisst, auch guter PHP
Code dokumentiert sich selbst, Engagement, Leistungsbereitschaft im Team, die Seite ist
in Ordnung, ok, das Video ist Cringe, also, Ups, ist es Chebathe, ist es Chebathe, ah
ne, das ist nicht Chebathe, ich hab gedacht, das ist Chebathe, ich hab gedacht, die wollen
einen verarschen, fast, ok, die sind mir schon mal sympathisch, man darf mit kurzer Hose
am Rechner setzen, Team Zelda, oh Gott, Moment, ich muss mal die Musik kurz ausmachen, äh,
da sind wir stehen geblieben, ja, alter, die Musik, das übertreibt es mal nicht, oh,
hier ist es kahn Huang, ich meine das ist es
Ja, es ist super mit den Kollegen im Team, das macht wirklich Spaß.
Und auch generell finde ich es schön, dass hier einfach so viel Vertrauen in mich gesetzt wurde,
weil ich habe ja als Student hier angefangen, habe meine Abschlussarbeit hier geschrieben,
direkt eine Rolle als Teamleiter bekommen. Das war für mich natürlich eine mega Ehre und
das macht einfach Spaß dann. Wahrscheinlich wollte das keiner machen sonst.
Generell passiert ja auch gerade die Umstellung auf GitLab im Hintergrund,
dass da alles über Docker-Qt da läuft und im Kubernetes und schnicki schnacki.
Ich finde das Video nicht schlecht. Also die macht den Eindruck, als weiß sie wovon sie redet und
sie labert nicht im Kreis rum. Sobald das dann zeitlich mal passt, ist Relax Day dann auch einfach
sehr offen, da diese bessere Lösung umzusetzen und das macht einfach Spaß dann. Da würde ich
mich ohne Scheiß nach dem Video, würde ich mir tatsächlich überlegen mich dazu bewerben. Also
mache ich nicht, aber wenn ich jetzt suchen würde, ich fand das wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Die labert nicht so sinnlos im Kreis rum. Ich finde es viel cringier, wenn du Leute irgendwo
da sitzen hast so nach dem Motto, ich arbeite bei der ABC GmbH und ich bin dann direkt nach meinem
Studio hingekommen und ich war so überrascht, was das für ein toller innovativer und moderner
Arbeitgeber ist. Ich könnte mir keinen schöneren Arbeitsplatz vorstellen bei der ABC GmbH. Jeder
Tag ist eine neue Herausforderung. Mein Team ist das Beste. Aber das ist doch vollkommen okay
gewesen. Das ist doch nice. Ja also da kann ich mich nicht
bestellen. Übrigens, hier hatte ich. Okay es. Mir hatte mir hat es hier vorher wieder. Oh das
das das sieht das sieht cringeig aus. Allein schon vom Thumbnail her. Also da bin ich mir
jetzt nicht so sicher. Zeig mal her. Sagen wir haben die alle irgendwie die gleiche Musik drin.
Und warum stehen ihre Azubis random auf dem Parkplatz. Nee machen sie gar nicht. Hi ich
bin der Luca. Ich bin 21 Jahre alt und ich absolviere meine Ausbildung bei der
GRIESAWA Logistics Group in Bad Zecking als Fachinformatiker für System Integration.
Es kam gerade ein Ticket rein. Oh jetzt jetzt Jyra Ticket Leute hier. Es kam gerade ein Ticket
rein. Ich bin kurz unten im Serverraum. Okay meistens werden Anfragen von Mitarbeitern in
unserem zentralen Ticketsystem verarbeitet. Noch der gute alte Turnschuh Admin. So mag ich das.
Von den Mitarbeitern der IT Abteilung verarbeitet. Es besteht aber auch noch die Möglichkeit Anfragen
über Telefon zu stellen. Das heißt man ruft einfach eine zentrale Nummer an und dort. Und
da hat jeder Bock drauf Telefonsupport zu machen. Ich werde mit euch. Dann jemand
mitte wegen dem Problem melden und mit Leuten kommunizieren. Das ist ja das schlimmste.
Top Sound. Okay ich schau mir das mal an. Oh nein Drucker fixen. Hört mal auf.
Den muss doch was besseres eingefallen sein um ihre
Fachinformatiker Ausbildung zu bewerben als Drucker fixen.
Und warum hängt da überhaupt so treu Schnee beim Drucker. Mit Kabelmanagement habe ich keine
Probleme. Ihr hättet das früher bei uns im Rechenzentrum sehen müssen. Das war auch so.
Ja dementsprechend haben wir doch aus Versehen schon mal Wackelkontakte ausgelöst an Servern.
Weil egal andere Geschichte vielleicht nicht ganz so schlimm. Aber es war bei uns halt voll.
Bei uns hattest du quasi eine komplette Wand. Nur Kabel. Aber warum. Warum steht das neben
dem Drucker. Warum ist das nicht mal. Zumindest. Zumindest. Ich glaube da ist sogar Klaas. Da
ist Klaas davor. Aber ja okay ist egal. Besonders wichtig in der Logistik. Jo was war jetzt mit dem
Drucker. Grießhaber sind auch die Scanner. Die Scanner spielen eine zentrale Rolle. Weil
der Grießhaber Logistik Group. Weil diese Scanner. Scanner. Im ganzen Lager in Gebrauch sind. Heißt
die IT ist doch immer direkt der erste Ansprechpartner wenn mit den Scannern ein Fehler
passiert. Oder wenn es Probleme gibt allgemein beim Scannen. Oder wenn. Machen viele so. Ich
habe das noch nie gesehen. Drucker im Serverraum. Mit dem Netzwerk. Was ich an meinem Berufsalltag
schätze. Ist das mein. Ist das. Ich habe erst gedacht das ist. Ein Mainframe. Aber. Ist es
anscheinend nicht. Was ist es denn. Das ist Dell oder. Ist EMC Dell. Ist es ein Storage. Ist es ein Dell Storage. Warte mal. Lass mich mal grad gucken. EMC. Dell EMC VNX Series. Ja das ist der. Das wusste
ich doch dass mir das bekannt vorkommt. Arbeit sehr abwechslungsreich gestaltet ist. Sowas
haben wir auch. Nicht das Ding aber von EMC. Und die IT nicht komplett voneinander getrennt
ist. Oh jawoll. Die gute alte Konsole. So muss das. So muss das. So mag ich das. Wie
zwei Zahnräder ineinander arbeiten und voneinander abhängig sind. Welche Zahnräder arbeiten
ineinander. Sehr abwechslungsreich gestaltet ist. Und dass die Logistik und die IT nicht
komplett voneinander getrennt ist. Sondern dass beide quasi wie zwei Zahnräder ineinander
arbeiten und voneinander abhängig sind. Damit sie gut funktionieren. Ich frage mal bei meinem
Kollegen Simon nach. Wie es ihm im Serverraum ergeht. Pass auf Leute. Huge Acting Skills
bestimmt jetzt. Hi. Ja hi Simon. Bist du schon weiter gekommen. Ich frage mich ob
die das Video freiwillig gemacht haben. Oder ob man gesagt hat ihr macht jetzt gefällig
das Video. Serverraum. Ja klappt wieder. Der Drucker war noch im falschen V-Lan drin.
Oh. Ohne Scheiß auch wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen gemeckert habe. Also vom Inhalt her ist das
gar nicht schlecht. Ich mein jemand der sich für die Ausbildung interessiert wird das
wahrscheinlich soll ich viel sagen. Aber das sind genau die Probleme wo ich mir vorstellen
könnte die da tagtäglich auftreten. Warum auch immer der Drucker im falschen V-Lan
drin ist. Ich mein warum ist er auf einmal heute in einem anderen V-Lan als gestern.
Aber gut ich mein das sind Probleme die drehten auf. Und warum druckte er nur schwarz weiß
wenn er im falschen V-Lan ist. Hi ich bin der Simon 19 Jahre alt und im zweiten Lehrjahr
als Fachinformatiker bei Grieshaber. Ich habe damals hier mein Praktikum gemacht und habe
danach dann direkt die Ausbildung hier angefangen. Was ich sehr gut finde bei Grieshaber ist
dass auf die Azubis geachtet wird unter anderem durch der Onboarding Day und durch viele Azubis
Events. Ok das wäre für mich schon mal der Cringe schlechthin wenn ich den Onboarding
Day machen muss. Guckt euch das mal an irgendwelche komischen Waldausflüge. Ach du Kajun please
lass die Leute doch einfach ihre Arbeit machen. Ach du. Also das nicht dass ich was gegen
die Schaukel hätte aber ich behaupte mal die Schaukel hätte was gegen mich. Wer weiß
da mache ich den noch in komischen in komischen Dinger kaputt. In der IT haben wir ein sehr
junges Team und ein sehr familiäres Team. Bei ihm ist das kein Problem. Was mir sehr
gefällt an der Spedition ist der Kontakt zu den Kunden und Mitarbeitern. Und durch eben
die Logistik und die Speditionsbranche haben wir oft auf Englisch oder Französisch zu
tun auch durch die verschiedenen Standorte in den unterschiedlichen Ländern was das
ganze einfach noch ein bisschen ausmacht und was dadurch dann eben auch nicht so eintönig
wird. Ich glaube es ist gar nicht schlecht das war am Anfang ein bisschen unglücklich
das Video aber ich glaube es kann man durchaus machen. Was auch ein Grund war wieso ich mich
für den Beruf entschieden habe weil ohne IT einfach heutzutage gar nichts mehr geht.
Das ist ja auch so. Wer mischt diese Videos immer ab? Haben sie Recht? Erstmal Drohnenrundflug
in Bad Säckingen. Was? Ich glaube wenn man einmal angefangen hat diese Videos zu gucken
dann kriegt man immer so Zeug empfohlen. Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf. Guckt euch mal
an. YouTube ist jetzt der Meinung ich möchte Feasy Videos empfohlen bekommen hier. Der
sieht wenigstens aus wie ich mir so ein Feasy vorstelle. Zudem hätte ich gleich Vertrauen
im Support. Da wisst ihr halt Ahnung. So wen haben wir denn sonst noch hier? Nix mehr.
Was ist das Azubi? Azubi Fakten. WMX oder BMW? Mal gucken. Mal gucken ob es BMW schafft
gescheites Video zu machen. Das Intro ist schon. Das ist so Influencer Style. Das ist so Influencer
Style. Hallo? Das ist ein Feasy Video. Als nächstes würde ich erwarten da sagt ich
bin euch so dankbar für die Abonnenten. Schön dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt. Ohne euch
wäre ich nichts. Hätte ich jetzt noch drauf gewartet. Also auf gehts. Ach du Kacke. Ach
Moment. Der ist gar nicht von BMW. Das ist wirklich irgendein Influencer Dude oder was?
Wer ist das? Alter wer mischt diese Videos immer ab? Das ist doch nicht euer Ernst. Pepe?
Ach Peppa. Chancen vertan. Muss mal kurz gucken wie viele Subs hat der auf Instagram? 6000.
Hey Laura ich habe gerade deine Freundin Peppa kennengelernt. Zufälligerweise steht Laura
genau daneben. Arbeitet ihr also mit Robotern? Ja wir programmieren hier beispielsweise auch
mit Peppa. Was haben denn Roboter mit Autos zu tun? Die Roboter helfen uns bei den Autos
hauptsächlich in der Produktion aber auch hier im IT Bereich. Krass. Sag mal was macht
denn der Arbeit am meisten Spaß? Am meisten gefakt mit dass wir... Jetzt wird was zusammen
gefakt. Jetzt wird was zusammen gefakt. Bei diesen Fragen kannst du nur gefakt antworten.
... wo wir alle zusammen arbeiten. Jeder von uns kann seinen Arbeitsalltag selbst einstellen
und gestalten. Da habe ich so meine Zweifel. Das kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren wenn
jeder machen kann was er will. Und wenn wir beispielsweise mit Peppa programmieren sehen
wir am Ende was für ein tolles Ergebnis wir haben. Finde ich wirklich wichtig. Sag mal
bist du gar nicht an den Fahrzeugen? Selbst wenn man so super agile und agil ist teilt
man sich nicht einfach random irgendwie was selbst ein. Da gibt es trotzdem einen Backlog
und einen Plan was man macht. Aber Melanie die kann dir weiterhelfen. Alles klar dann
werde ich dich mal besuchen. Danke. Auf gehen wir zu Melanie. Hey Melanie schön dass du
dir Zeit genommen hast. Hallo. Du sag mal wo sind wir hier eigentlich? Wir sind hier
gerade bei einem Standpunkt von BMW Motorrad. Wo hauptsächlich die IT so geschrieben wird
für die Handlersysteme. Also quasi die Diagnose wenn ein Motorrad kaputt ist, dass man es
ansteckt und sagt hey was geht. Da war das Video übersteuert. Weißt du was sie da getrieben
haben? Das ist ziemlich wichtig. Und was sind deine Aufgaben in der Ausbildung? Also ich
als Azubi lerne natürlich auch alles mögliche drum rum. Die IT Strategien und alles. Aber
der Fokus liegt definitiv auf den verschiedenen Programmiersprachen. Okay was denn? Was für
Programmiersprachen? Das würde mich ernsthaft wenn ich mich da bewähren würde interessieren
um was für Programmiersprachen. Mit dem kann ich mich ganz witzig auf das Motorrad drauf
schalten. Das heißt wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel einfach das Licht ändern will. Wow das ist
ja krass. Boah. Und was kannst du noch damit achten? Eigentlich alles was das Herz begehrt.
Das ist quasi nur mal zum Testen für den Händler. Hey geht es noch? Geht die Lampe
noch? Genau. Das wirkt überhaupt nicht gestellt. Du sag mal mit BMW verbinde ich eigentlich
auch Autos. Kannst du mir da auch was zeigen? Klar aber dann solltest du besser zum Adriano
gehen. Super mache ich. Danke dir. Also die müssen unbedingt sich mal einen besseren
Video. Also generell diese ganzen Azubi Videos bisher die hatten immer zu leise Stimmen und
zu laute Musik. Hey Adriano. Servus Easy. Du ich war schon gerade bei Melanie und sie hat
gemeint dass du der Richtige bist wenn es um Autos geht. Na klar doch. Und er heißt
Easy? Easy. Jawoll. Kannst du mir verraten was du in deiner Ausbildung so machst? Also
das erste was ich mache ist ich lerne wie mein Softwarecoach schreibt und das machen
wir um Aufgaben die voll von Menschen durchgeführt werden jetzt von Maschinen durchführen zu
lassen. Das ist automatisch und geht einfach schneller. Das hört sich ziemlich komplizierter.
Konkretes Beispiel. Ich habe gerade eine App und programmiert es so dass sie sich selber
ausführt und diese App kann am Ende mit dem Auto sprechen. Hä? Hä? Was? Nochmal. Oh
Moment. Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Was? Nochmal. Nochmal. Das ist automatisch.
Moment. Na klar doch. Kannst du mir verraten was du in deiner Ausbildung so machst? Also
das erste was ich mache ist ich lerne wie mein Softwarecoach schreibt und das machen
wir um Aufgaben die voll von Menschen durchgeführt werden jetzt von Maschinen durchführen zu
lassen. Also er programmiert irgendwelche Bandroboter oder wie oder was? Also spricht
das was Leute früher am Fließband gemacht haben? Programmiert er jetzt quasi irgend
so einen Greifarm der das macht oder sowas? Okay. Das ist automatisch und geht einfach
schneller. Das hört sich ziemlich komplizierter. Konkretes Beispiel. Okay. Ich habe gerade
eine App und programmiert es so dass sie sich selber ausführt und die. Ach jetzt kapiere
ich das. Der testet die App beziehungsweise ne der testet die Steuerung für die für
den Kram. Ich glaube jetzt kapiere ich das. Okay. Das ist das ist eine Test App die quasi
checken kann ob mit dem Auto alles in Ordnung ist. Also keine Ahnung. Auto ist ist teilweise
zusammengebaut. Dann wird das gestartet und das checkt dann ob das Auto nach dem selbst
check sagt es ist alles okay. Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Das habe ich am Anfang echt
nicht kapiert. Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Können wir uns das mal anschauen? Ja klar.
Super. Also was kannst du mir jetzt zeigen? Pass mal auf. Hat er gerade gesagt Alter.
Vorstellt können wir uns das mal anschauen? Ja klar. Super. Also was kann. Das sagt man
doch heute gar nicht mehr. Das hat man gesagt wo ich jung war. Sind jetzt Boomer neuerdings
schon 20 oder was? Heute hat man gesagt ey Digga. Oder. Ach der sagt also. Ach so. Ach
ich dachte er hat gesagt ich habe gesagt Alter. Digga zeig mal her. Kannst du mir jetzt zeigen?
Pass mal auf. Boah jetzt hast du mich aber erschrocken. Ja Hupen machen wir eigentlich
normalerweise nur um das Auto auf dem Parkdeck wenn wir es nicht mehr finden eben wieder
zu finden. Aber ich kann zum Beispiel auch aufsperren und zusperren. Heißt jetzt kannst
du mit deinem Handy jeden BMW aufsperren? Ja so einfach ist es nicht. Wir haben natürlich
eine Baujahr. Würde ich jetzt auch sagen. Würde ich jetzt auch sagen. Das heißt ab
einem bestimmten Baujahr gibt es nur und der Fahrer muss das bestätigen. Das ist echt
ein nicer Wagen ist aber nicht dein. Da ist aber kein Fahrrad drin. Doch. BMW bekommen
wir als Azubis direkt günstige Konditionen so dass wir die Abstart mieten können. Hammer
darf ich mal in der Runde drehen? Ja klar. Ich wusste dass jetzt Musik kommt. Ich habe
es geahnt. Das war jetzt eine geile Fahrt. Vielen Dank Adriano und vor allem vielen Dank
BMW für den coolen Tag. Und jetzt nochmal für euch die wichtigste Zeit zu mitschreiben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen weil man muss sagen wirklich viel erfahren hat man in dem Video
jetzt nicht. Die Ausbildung dauert drei Jahre die ihr allerdings verkürzen könnt. Ausbildungsstart
ist immer im August oder im September. Bewerben könnt ihr euch allerdings ein Jahr im Voraus.
Okay das ist jetzt. Jetzt hätte BMW wahrscheinlich gerne. Aber ich kenne genug die sich nicht
ein Jahr im Voraus bewerben. Das hätten die alle gerne. Aber das kommt oft genug vor
dass es die Leute nicht machen. Ja ja ich weiß ich sage ja das hätten die gerne. Aber
es kommt oft genug vor dass das nicht praktiziert wird. Okay es kann ja sein dass BMW das macht.
Und BMW sagt wenn du es nicht machst dann nehmen wir dich halt nicht. Es ist ja denen
ihr gutes Recht. Die können ja machen was sie wollen.
Okay das heißt das finde ich schon mal ganz gut. Das heißt sie sagen damit nämlich auch
wir bilden das aus weil wir das brauchen. Das ist tatsächlich gut in München weiß
ich es nicht. Aber das ist ordentlich ja. 1000 Euro nicht? Nö. Also ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung wie es jetzt aktuell ist. Aber 1000 Euro im ersten Ausbildungsjahr klingt
richtig gut. Ich meine worauf wartet ihr noch? Hier ist der Link für alle weiteren Infos.
Ich hoffe euch hat das Video gefallen. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Peace. Peace. Okay ich
habe null erfahren wie das bei BMW so ist nach dem Video. Dann fand ich ohne Scheiß
von den ganzen Videos die wir bisher geguckt haben heute. Da fand ich die Relax Days eigentlich
am besten. Da wo der Chat gesagt hat null Cringe. Das war eigentlich super. Die hat
einfach nicht um den heißen Brei herum gelabert. Die hat einfach gesagt wie es ist. Max Silbermann
fünf Monate dankeschön für den Sub. Leute habt ihr mal auf die Uhr geguckt. Wisst ihr
was das heißt? Korrekt. Guckt er schläft schon. Also Leute wir sehen uns dann. Nächsten
Streben. Bis dann war es gut. Outro Musik noch. Bis dann. CU.